you probably have gone to a pharmacy or
doctor's office and slipped your arm
into a device like this as the cuff
squeezes and then gradually deflates it
varies the external pressure on an
artery in your arm a sensor inside the
cuff measures blood volume in the artery
and the device uses this data to
calculate your blood pressure
hypertension or high blood pressure is a
major risk factor for heart disease and
strokes but it often goes unrecognized
in developed countries forty five
percent of people with hypertension
aren't aware of it in developing
countries it's even higher at fifty five
percent that's why many want to increase
access to blood pressure screening tools
but the standard cuff method isn't very
portable not that many people own them
in the first place now researchers have
built a cuff 'less device to measure
blood pressure that is convenient and
accessible this new device uses the same
principle as the conventional arm cuff
but instead of a cuff varying the
external pressure on the artery in your
arm the user varies the external
pressure by steadily pressing their
finger against a special case attached
to a smartphone the device is embedded
with two sensors that measure blood
volume and applied pressure in the
finger artery the case transmits the
data via bluetooth to an app on the
smartphone which computes the blood
pressure and provides a visual display
to guide the user and show results
90% of participants got the hang of
using it after one or two tries the
smartphone based device was not quite as
precise as the arm cuff but comparable
to a finger cuff and it's the first time
this particular artery in the fingertip
has been shown to be an effective site
for blood pressure measurement because
smartphones already have nearly all the
hardware needed for this method you
could potentially ditch the case
altogether and just add a thin film
force sensor atop the phone's existing
optical sensor another advantage of this
system is that many measurements can be
made over time and then averaged to
eliminate error from incorrect usage or
blood pressure variations due to stress
physical activity and other factors
since it relies on the user to actively
press on the double sensor the device
cannot be used to measure blood pressure
at night which is clinically important
the team still needs to test with the
larger sample size and they plan to add
additional features including an alert
system to warn users of high blood
pressure and securely transmit the
results to caregivers after more
prototypes and tests researchers hope
that soon you'll only have to reach into
your pocket for an easy and accurate way
to measure blood pressure
[Music]